eu costumo dizer para os novos juízes
estão chegando a carreira e mesmo o
evento alunos nas universidades e é
extremamente importante a gente
continuar precisando nos livros que é
rico não racionais
a gente tem a sempre aprendendo mas
paralelamente a isto nós vamos estudar o
grande livro da vida nesse grande livro
da vida não está nas prateleiras nas
boas escolas nas bibliotecas das
universidades nunes à venda nas ruas de
várias igrejas divino da vida
nós vamos achar a poeira das ruas no
chão enlameado das favelas nos esgotos
dos portistas ano partiu da fundação
casa nas celas no nosso fracassado
sistema carcerário e na solidão nos
hospitais isso aprendeu aos 13 anos de
idade quando vai escapar de um exemplo
geografia eu fui fazer o reconhecimento
do que a uma favela uma favela que já
não existe mais em são paulo já foi a
maior favela de são paulo a favela do
vermelho e lá fugiram para a favela do
verdadeiro num mico churros uso
aos 13 anos de neve até aqui na série
ginasial sozinho o professor fauze sade
que era o meu professor jogar
de voto ela falou anos entrou sozinho
vai sozinho e outro de uma prancheta uma
folha de papel e uma caneta para servir
o que era uma favela e depois o dia
seguinte voltar os meus colegas de
classe que é uma favela e assim eu
ficaria livre do sangue de meio do ano
de jogar lá e eu lá eu conheci um anjo
uma menina liga magra magela imã minha
fúria de junho
mesmo no chão e eu tinha a minha idade
13 anos de idade a mônica e é
impressionado porque naquela marisa tona
saía uma grande barriga e eu vi
antecedente que amor e caos 13 anos de
idade estava grávida e conversando com a
mônica ela me contou que tinha sido
engravidada hurun dos seus cinco irmãos
mais velhos
ela nem sabe exatamente quem é esse
irmão porque isso aconteceu na escuridão
da noite na escuridão aquela comunidade
empobrecida onde eles moravam eu
confesso a vocês e isso veio na minha
cabeça com o rádio é que eu nunca mais
consegui sair da grande favela da ilha
logo quando entrei na faculdade é eu
quero dizer que para o meu orgulho eu
estudei na faculdade
o doutor farina não é só aqui na frente
é meu
os meus melhores amigos nós fizemos a
faculdade o jogo estava no segundo joão
coser o trabalho e os meninos noite é ea
faculdade durante esse período me reunir
dez rapazes e moças mexicanos s anos
fazendo reforço escolar numa favela que
exista hoje é faziam os reforços
tornarmos de semana e aos 34 anos atrás
eu vou pegar nessa favela existe há
verdadeiros já não existe mais um
milagre e sigma sony com óbvio aquelas
crianças e jovens com os mais nós
havíamos trabalhado é em reforço de
português matemática geografia história
e passando noções se valer da galinha da
turma e se oferecia o serrote e se
tornaram o inter solitários e passaram a
trazer a comunidade deles coisas
absolutamente importantes creche
laboratório médico ponto de ônibus a
porta tudo isso me disse um dos meus
meninos e os alunos até a favela graças
àqueles estudantes e mais de mel durante
dez anos trabalhando com eles
depois disso foi para as ruas trabalhar
com crianças e crianças moradores de rua
todas elas com ameaças como o último
situação do marcel foi 15 anos nas ruas
três vezes por semana nós vimos para
duas noites e tentava resgatar aquela
criança a dor
foram momentos muito emocionantes
aprendi muito com ele os moradores rua e
te deum time marcou profundamente né
esse menino é viciar uma droga e naquela
época nos anos 70 eu estava nas ruas nas
ruas daquela época tinha corsa
temer é ter né o esmalte de unha a
cachaça e tinha e ainda tem né
é mas ele era viciado em cocaína
eu fui é a filha de um engenheiro e de
uma professora tenha sido o rosto de
fora de casa porque começou a perder
tudo de casa
a mulher foi socorrida fora e eu acabei
e estou bombaram para poder sustentar
essa grandalhão e eu acabei cometendo
uma loucura dessas muitas do cometa até
hoje
convidei esse garoto até é advogado essa
é e convidei esse garoto a trabalhar eu
sei para o que acontece é linchado pelos
meus ossos e secretárias para recitar
embora estou trazendo um menino pedro
almada iniciado em nova york e eles
falaram antes e nem nos antigos mas
acabou se vamos ganhar você na janela
mas não existe né
nenê foi um ótimo funcionário fazer o
tratamento no hospital das clínicas
voltou para a casa dos pais o calor
estudar e nem a saída é uma ávida duas
recaídas crescente países podem ainda
cinco e karina seis paridas 7 recaídas e
marina 8 uma tentativa de resgate
eu disse a ele uma fase que foi a
seguinte
ele me legou disso agora há pouco tempo
atrás eu disparei assim para você ver
nos a você quer uma chato eu já conheci
na minha vida eu não aguento mais você
mas passado esse tempo todo né passei a
amar você como argentino um fio e filho
a gente não desiste
vou embora de novo ele foi e não voltou
para as ruas de novo
hoje é professor da fundação getúlio
vargas
admirável
alah que morreu em são paulo se move
hoje no rio de janeiro
o trabalho maravilhoso com crianças e
adolescentes em flor redução em situação
de rua muito bem e eu em 1985 era
diretor de uma editora
o meu tesouro é um cara na porta ele de
repente negou a pneumonia morreu e saber
qual o met com o que tinha acontecido eo
médico me disse ele morreu
uma eu falei me fala sobre a dita como o
perfil mostrar para você aires e fica
falando e mostrou os primeiros doentes
são antes completamente a libertadores e
eu como tinha condição de 2 variados
coisas quiser sair nas ruas e vou
trabalhar com white e som ainda não é
completamente abandonados por suas
famílias
nessa época eu cheguei à magistratura de
são paulo
me tornei o juiz
primeiro o tribunal já não existem mais
é o primeiro tribunal de alçada numa
coisa tornei desembargador no tribunal
de justiça
e é isso foi no início dos anos 90
posso dizer para vocês e trabalho feito
ou os juízes trabalham muitos o
toneladas de processos mas sempre há
gente em que arrumar um fibo ué
eu continuei trabalhando com anúncios
mas em 97 que é eu fui procurado
sensacional
o menino e que remontar
uma organização a ong e contadores de
histórias a crianças hospitalizadas me
perguntou você é aquele juiz se trabalha
com adultos o angeloni é então a gente
mudar e e vela começarmos a trabalhar
com crianças né
vamos começar a trabalhar com eles em 97
nós mudamos o viva e deixe viver e é o
comecei a trabalhar com ele né
me tornei o tipo ló começamos a
trabalhar em quatro pessoas hoje não
somos 1.500 soldados espalhados em 97
hospitais
somos contadores de histórias e maneiras
diferentes
o gol aqui agora eu tirava estragar o
som povo a gente
há poucas histórias para crianças é cada
um de uma maneira diferente né
é um novelo joão outros dançando num eu
quis ser mais né diz um curso de mágica
mais mil que ir com um gol cada vez que
eu ia fazer uma mágica para tirar a
pombinha da cartola
a kombi não saía eo pessoal analisada
por um palhaço e ignorei então o tipo
autor não é às vezes usando maquiagem às
vezes usado por rádios de palhaço
o chapéu games enquanto quando eu saio
do hospital emílio ribas e já vou para o
universidad na aula as vezes que se a
maquiagem os alunos estranham a gente
tem que ser criativo né
outro dia li um livro fantástico sobre
as princesas e também só o bumbum
eu comecei agora chora de terror para
crianças e algum da rocha e descobri uma
coisa fantástica e soltar pum é uma das
coisas mais engraçadas e que fazem as
crianças morreram e então tem essa
máquina de solda turnê
deixa a criançada alucinada então vou
mostrar pra vocês
os diversos pontos
ficou só no discurso óbvio o número 1
número 2 e número 3
esse é mais unida iu 45 impressionante
ele enfim a gente tem que ser criativo
eu tenho a dizer que a gente não pode
desanimar alguns anos atrás numa véspera
de natal dia com poucas crianças as
finanças da casa e as crianças estavam
lá estavam com um país nós havia um
menino não é rotina gozo estava sozinho
eu resolvi passar brincando e contando
histórias para ele um menino que tinha
de 12 para 13 anos de idade fazendo de
tudo é que aquele menino na delegacia
até a véspera de natal o menino nada
falou nada disse
e quando chega o final do expediente
seis horas a data a lei não valeu a pena
que ele merece perder natal
e os meus netos os toc kan é o menino
que eu não conheço e nada falou nada
assim na o meu se mexiam não valeu a
pena
e quando o é no mínimo de arroz
a gente não sabia recebia com as amarrou
populares os olhinhos mas quando estava
lavando as mãos e tirando meus anéis
para ir embora
eu senti um puxão no jacaré e é aquele
menino e me disse o seguinte
pode não parecer mas eu estou aqui eu
voltar mais perdia a esperança né ea
vontade de continuar trabalhando pelas
pessoas
até porque uma vez seu livro antigo
livro dos judeus ou chorar
uma frase e me marcou muito 220
se você salvar uma pessoa na verdade
está salvando a unidade a obrigar o z
[Aplausos]